I want to marry your daughter mrs.
Burney no bells and whistles just the
two of us exchanging vows finally make
this official pretty little engagement
Kayla proposed to Hannah on Tuesday
night's episode up PLL did you really
mean what you said
what to my mom
do you really care I need to know if I
don't know if you said it just to
distract her pana I would marry you
right this second if we could find a
bear who's license
we connected to Brandon in April Ashley
Benson Toby PA Hanna does get a happy
ending my hand is going to be very happy
I can't say much
this no rune but yes I think that the
fans are gonna be happy with Hanna I am
and the hail of wedding is something we
predicted in 2016 before season seven
even premiered Marlene also told me
there is a wedding you think that could
be a hail of wedding that would be
really cool it takes so much to like get
them back to a place where they're going
to get married didn't sit on a plane
gonna take a lot but anything can happen
like I said PLL is an interesting world
[Music]